Cook County prosecutors abruptly and
bewildering Li drop all charges against
hate crime hoaxer jussie Smollett who
now like OJ will no doubt go on the hunt
for the real attackers we analyze how
this miscarriage of justice happened
then speaking of fakers Alexandria o
Cassio Cortes encourages her Democrat
colleagues not to vote for the green New
Deal and finally David Brooks draws a
moral equivalence between Russia hoaxers
and the Russia hoaxed in the New York
Times I'm Michael Knowles and this is
the Michael Noel's show
[Music]
the hoaxes strike back today
Jesse Smollett the green New Deal even
Russia they're all striking back fantasy
is trying to reassert itself against
reality let's see how that works but
first let's make a little money honey
with mint mobile there are a lot of
things in life that aren't right carpet
in showers eating dip with your fingers
paying too much for your phone bill
those things are not right at all
thanks to mint mobile you don't have to
overpay for wireless anymore
with mint mobile you can cut your
wireless bill down to just 15 bucks a
month
they've reimagined Wireless making it
easy and online only which means you can
pass you they can pass the savings on
directly to you you can save over a
thousand bucks a year with mint mobile
without sacrificing quality service 15
bucks a month means 15 bucks a month how
do they do it it's because right now you
are overpaying for unlimited internet
and dad and all that you're never gonna
use and they are gouging you for this
just say nothing of all those hidden
fees with mint mobile you choose between
plans that have 3 8 or 12 gigabytes of
4G LTE data and you stop paying for
unlimited data you'll never use if
you're not 100% satisfied mint mobile
has you covered with their 7 day
money-back guarantee ditch your old
wireless bill start paying a fraction
without sacrificing quality service with
mint mobile get your new wireless plan
for just 15 bucks a month get the plan
shipped to your door for free go to mint
mobile comm slash Knowles Keo wles
that's mint mobile.com / Knowles Keo
wles cut your wireless bill down to 15
bucks a month and get free shipping on
your mint mobile plan at MIT mobile comm
/ Knowles the Empire Strikes Back the
hoaxers strike back jussie Smollett
walks free a true miscarriage of justice
I got to tell you something folks I'm
starting to have a little hunch that
maybe Chicago is corrupt I don't want to
be telling tales at a school I don't
want to be running my mouth if that
isn't true but I'm just I don't know
what it is something of
Chicago just doesn't seem quite right
and so now Cook County prosecutors over
there have dropped all charges against
friend of the obamas Jesse Smollett guy
who smiles in photos with the Obamas
Jesse Smollett who also come from
Chicago now what are the terms of this
he has to surrender his bond so when he
was arrested he posted posts $10,000
bond and he has to do 16 hours of
community service so less than one day
of community service and he surrenders
his bond and then he goes free this is
what the state attorney said quote we
looked at all the facts and
circumstances of the case the resources
that we have our priority of addressing
violent crime smollett's criminal
background his lack of criminal
background he didn't have any felonies
or violent felonies in his background
based on all those facts and
circumstances this was a just outcome in
the case here's what Jesse Smollett says
about it first of all I want to thank my
family my friends the incredible people
of Chicago and all over the country in
the world who have prayed for me who
have supported me who've shown me so
much love no one will ever know how much
that has meant to me and I will forever
be grateful
I want you to know that not for a moment
was it in vain
I've been truthful and consistent on
every single level since day one I would
not be my mother's son if I was capable
of one drop of what I've been accused of
this has been an incredibly difficult
time honestly one of the worst of my
entire life but I'm a man of faith and
I'm a man that has knowledge of my
history and I would not bring my family
our lives or the movement through a fire
like this I just wouldn't so I want to
thank my legal counsel from the bottom
of my heart and I would also like to
thank the state of Illinois for
attempting to do what's right
now I'd like nothing more than to just
get back to work and move on with my
life
but make no mistakes I will always
continue to fight for the justice
equality and betterment of marginalized
people everywhere so again thank you for
all the support thank you for faith and
thank you too god bless y'all thank you
very much where to begin he says he's
been truthful since day one of this
whole ordeal if he's been truthful why
does he have to surrender his ten
thousand dollar bond and do community
service if he's done nothing wrong
why does he still have to be punished I
mean look there are so many reasons here
why it's obvious that the guy did it but
just in the first place if he actually
were innocent I mean if he actually were
innocent you wouldn't have signed checks
from him paying off the people who
attacked him you wouldn't have him
getting caught an obvious lies you
wouldn't have had any of this but even
if that were that let's say you actually
were innocent then he would go out there
and say this is a miscarriage of justice
I'm not surrendering my ten thousand
dollar bond I'm not doing community
service because I did nothing wrong and
I'm gonna fight hard of course he
doesn't do that because this was a
crooked deal and he got let off the hook
because he's a famous rich guy because
Chicago is SuperDuper corrupt and
because he plays the the racial and
sexual victim and so he gets let off the
hook
and it's just the arrogant it's just the
fact I mean he's yeah I guess he's
pretty
on that show Empire but he's giving a
terrible performance here and he gave a
terrible performance on TV when he was
first being interviewed about the attack
he says I would never I would never do
this I would not be my mother's son well
I don't know I guess it's a wise man
knows his own parents or something
because this guy obviously did it and
then I would never let the movement down
like that what movement what movement
are you letting what the I don't even
know I don't know because he plays the
victim as a gay guy he plays the victim
as a black guy he plays the victim
probably as an actor the most oppressed
group of people of all and yet he did it
he's obviously guilty and what's so
awful about this is the State Attorney's
Office while forcing him to take this
punishment is in a sense forcing him to
acknowledge guilt but they're not
explicitly forcing him to acknowledge
guilt so he gets to go out there and say
I'm perfectly innocent here's my ten
thousand dollars he'll do community
service for some corrupt organization
but there you go there you go doesn't
even have to acknowledge it you know
this is bad because even left-wing a
former chief of staff to Barack Obama
mayor of Chicago Rahm Emanuel is coming
out strong against these actions where
is the accountability in the system
you cannot have because of a person's
position one set of rules apply to them
and another set of rules apply to
everybody else in another way you're
seeing this play out in the universities
where people pay extra to get their kids
a special position in universities now
you have a person because of their
position and background who's getting
treated in a way that nobody else would
ever sorry about that would
don't get near I'm doing near my sermon
here that would ever get close did this
type of treatment he makes a good point
but you don't what he is doing is
relating this to the injustice in that
university scandal saying there's one
set of rules for rich famous people and
there's another set of rules for
everybody else but you even see this in
the relation to the Russia hoax because
the hoaxers are unrepentant this is the
problem I mean this is why conservatives
once we finish celebrating that this two
year narrative from Democrats completely
fell apart over the weekend now we're a
little bit angry because you've got
people who have been pushing this lie
for two years they're unrepentant say
now yeah no I never mind lalala don't
care about reality lalala I didn't do it
I would never do this lalala - giant
Nigerian anti black racists and I'm
friends with him that I paid thousands
of dollars to attacked me because I'm a
black gay guy lalalalalalala that's what
they're doing it's Russian collusion all
over again and the question is how is
this going to be remembered the at least
rahm emanuel comes out there at least
rahm emanuel says this is a miscarriage
of justice but how is already this is
being spun by CNN by people who watch
CNN which i guess is just sort of people
walking through airports but by people
who read the new york times by people
who pay attention to the mainstream
media by people who are listening to
gossip mills on social media they're
saying gosh well I guess Jesse didn't do
it they let him off the hook I guess he
didn't do it even wolf blitzer on CN n
is saying well come on I mean maybe he
didn't do it and rahm emanuel goes on
CNN just so that no one thinks he's he's
mincing words and lays it
out in excellent detail was the picture
pick painful was the full picture
painted by the evidence perhaps not as
compelling as what was presented to the
ground repelling enough it was
compelling enough wouldn't they say the
evidence presented to the grand juries
what brought the charges but did new
questions arise in the subsequent made
from more evidence that might be honest
that's not what the that's not what the
state's attorney just said today they
said in fact the police did a good job
and the evidence holds up and he
actually did commit the hoax they're
saying $10,000 and two days of community
service is good enough and I don't
believe not only is it not good enough
especially when he's walking around
thinking that he is actually innocent
not guilty and be he's innocent not on
not only legally and a criminal justice
sense he is also guilty in my view of a
moral crime which is to use the hate
crimes to advance his own career for
selfish reasons and that to me is where
there's a moral violation in a rip
because he went out and spoke on ABC to
the country as an african-american and a
gay man about being a victim of a crime
and then what comes forward and what we
actually now know to be the case and
even the state's attorney today he
acknowledged is the fact that that was
all a hoax he says it very well Rahm
Emanuel a smart guy is a partisan he's a
Democrat he's he is what he is but he's
making a clear point here and so you
have to ask yourself why is Rahm doing
this I mean Rahm is as much a party man
as anybody else he worked for the
Clintons he worked for Obama he's mayor
of Chicago the most corrupt Democrat
city in the country so why is he coming
out so strongly against this
intersectional example of politics why
is he coming out so strongly against
this hoax he's doing it because it's so
absurd he's doing it because it's in
defensible if it were defensible and it
would help him he would probably defend
it but it's indefensible it's pure
corruption and Rahm Emanuel doesn't want
to be lumped in with this if the Cook
County prosecutors want to debase
themselves I mean I don't know if it's
possible even to do that to people who
were so degraded as as quick County
prosecutors but he doesn't want to be
lumped in with them he has national
ambitions this guy wants to run for
president he doesn't want to be a part
of this even the Chicago Tribune says
that this is indefensible a right quote
it's an indefensible decision a deal
hashed out in secret with this is
outrageous smollett not even required to
take ownership of his apparent hoax it
is outrageous we know that but why else
why else are these people coming out
against it why else is maybe this not
over
you've got the Empire actor strikes back
you've got the fantasy striking back
against reality but Jesse Smollett might
still face federal charges because
actually the more serious crime then
faking this 3 a.m. during a polar vortex
carrying a subway salad getting attacked
by anti black Nigerians wearing Magga
hats or whatever nonsense he pretended
happened hoax more more egregious than
that is that he sent a hate letter to
himself and reported this as a hate
crime and as a threat that's a federal
matter that's not up to Cook County
prosecutors that's not up to Chicago
that's not up to whatever corrupt
machine jesse smollett it has access to
that's up to the feds something tells me
that the federal government is not going
to take too kindly to this they might
take a harsher approach than these
crooked prosecutors something tells me
Jesse Smollett we have not heard the
last of him and so now the question is
is he going to go back to Empire Empire
of course wants him back they've they've
got this plausibility in defending him
now he's a gotten a lot of attention hit
the ratings will increase so they kind
of want him back apparently the cast is
split on this half of them think that he
did it and half of them are idiots I
guess that's the breakdown and so
they're kind of split that they don't
know what's going to happen Empire would
be very unwise to take this guy back it
would be wise in the short term because
they'll get better ratings they veer
wise in the long term because this
federal matter isn't over and doing 16
hours of community service for some fake
bogus crooked organization in Chicago
and surrendering a ten thousand dollar
bond
ain't gonna cut it there and the hoax is
going to reassert itself we've got to
get to the green New Deal speaking of
hoaxes but first let's make a little
money honey with bowl and branch bowl
and branch oh you know I've been on the
road a lot over the last few weeks going
to do cut campus speeches and all I
dream about when I'm able to fall asleep
on the road is just getting back to my
bowl and branch sheets oh how I love
them they feel so much better than
everything that I had slept on for my
previous bachelor days you don't need to
take sleeping pills you don't need if
you want a good night's sleep you just
need to change your sheets that's why
you should check out Boland branch
everything they make from bedding to
blankets is made from pure 100% organic
cotton which means they start out super
soft and they get even softer over time
you can buy directly from them so you're
essentially paying wholesale prices
luxury sheets can cost up to a thousand
bucks in the store but Boleyn branch
sheets just a couple hundred bucks
everyone who tries Boleyn branch sheets
loves them that's why they have
thousands of five-star reviews
Forbes Wall Street Journal Fast Company
are all talking about them even three
u.s. presidents sleep on Boland branch
sheets shipping is free you can try them
for 30 nights if you don't love them
send them back for a refund but I doubt
that you'll want to send them back
there's no risk no reason not to give
them a try right now my listeners will
get $50 off your first set of sheets at
Boleyn branch kaam promo code michel mi
CH AE l do it you will not regret it
these things are fabulous Boland branch
comm for $50 off your first set of
sheets bol L and branch comm promo code
Michael Boleyn branch comm promo code
Michael we got another hoax not just
Jesse's Smollett we've got the green new
deal hoax so you know cocaine Mitch
master of the Senate comes back and
schedules a vote for the green new deal
yesterday he schedules this vote and AOC
Alexandria Casio Cortese wrote the draft
legislation all of the Democrats in the
Senate who are running for president
didn't just endorse it they coasts
sponsored that legislation they
co-sponsored this green New Deal
so Mitch McConnell said ok let's vote on
it you're all co-sponsoring it let's
vote on the green New Deal and they went
nuts do you know how many Democrats
voted for it zero this is zero Democrats
vote now they couldn't vote no on it
either because then they would be
totally exposed as hypocrites and frauds
so instead what they did at Alexandria
Ocasio cortezes encouragement is they
voted present they didn't vote for the
legislation that she wrote and they all
co-sponsored here is mazie Hirono
senator from Hawaii Senate Rick's from
Hawaii on the Judiciary Committee trying
to explain this bewildering action to
MSNBC on the green New Deal there was a
procedural motion today why did so many
Democrats vote present on it instead of
voting YES for it because this was just
a sham so-called debate by Mitch
McConnell he wanted to divide the
Democrats and the bottom line is they
agree New Deal is an aspirational
document that says we recognize the
science behind climate change unlike
Trump and the Republicans and all of the
climate deniers who want to stick their
heads in the sand well but and this and
that look is that a butterfly yet hey
you look over there right it's just a
mazie Hirono shape hole in the wall
she's trying to change the subject so
much just to clear up though which what
she said is she was supposed to answer
the question why did you not vote for
this what happened yesterday in the
Senate was there was a vote for the
legislation and mazie Hirono said this
is a sham this is not a debate right
it's not a debate that lady on MSNBC
didn't ask you about a debate because
there wasn't a debate yesterday was a
vote why do you want a debate the reason
that you have a debate aoc said this -
she said there were no committees there
were no debates the reason you would
have a debate is if someone proposes
legislation and then someone objects to
voting on
legislation you need the objection there
to have the debate it would be like me
saying I go up to the candy shop and I
say okay I want a piece of fudge I want
a piece of taffy and I want to borrow
chocolate and the person says okay here
you go I said what you're not even gonna
debate me a no sir you asked for those
things and now I'm giving them to you
yeah but you're not even gonna have a
committee to debate come on come on
that's a sham sir you asked me very
explicitly for something you told me
exactly what you wanted and now I'm
offering it to you why won't you take it
cuz I wanted to pay and a committee
that's the show obviously that's the
Sham this was Mitch McConnell's
brilliance because of course for so much
in the Senate you know one side wants
something the other side says no I won't
give you that and then they get into a
negotiation and they try to come to some
compromise but on this the green New
Deal is so absurd on its face it's so
impossible 93 trillion dollars destroys
every building in the entire country
within 10 years and then rebuilds all of
them eliminates 88 percent of the
American energy industry gets rid of
planes trains and automobiles totally up
ends gets rid of most of our political
Liberty Institute's socialized medicine
100 percent Institute's a universal
basic income it's all of these crazy
things it's such a joke that the
Democrats proposed it
they co-sponsor it they say we're in
100% and the Mitch McConnell says cool
aren't you gonna debate me nope no let's
just vote on it but we need committees
no we don't know you okay you made your
case we will not oppose what you're
doing we won't call for a debate there
you go you're the dog that caught the
car you're going to vote for it and then
they don't because they don't mean it
because they're hoaxers
so now mazie Hirono has to answer for
the indefensible and she just tries to
change the subject and make believe that
that climate change is not happening and
all of the growing number of natural
disasters that are taking people's lives
and costing our cities our businesses
our people billions of dollars which by
the way even as we speak we are going to
be dealing
with the disaster relief package because
of all of these many many disasters
natural disasters that are hitting us
more frequently and with greater impact
okay so your thesis is we're having all
of these natural disasters that are
happening really really frequently
that's your will examine whether that's
true or not in a little bit and all of
these natural disasters are being caused
by global warming we'll examine that in
a little bit but okay there's those are
your premises and we're and therefore
we're not going to vote to stop global
warming that's it all of everything's
going horribly because of global warming
therefore we're not going to vote to
stop global warming and then she starts
talking about a disaster relief package
which is a different piece of
legislation but we're not asking you
about that piece of legislation we're
asking you about the central piece of
legislation that all of you guys are
co-sponsoring that you then didn't vote
for very difficult to defendant the
other point she's making here though is
she's saying we're having all of these
natural disasters because of climate
change now it's so funny because when
Amy Klobuchar goes out and announces her
presidential campaign and she says the
central pillar of my campaign is going
to be global warming and fighting global
warming and she's standing in five feet
of snow and she's got snow pouring down
all over her head and then Donald Trump
points out he says it's kind of funny to
be talking about global warming while
you're covered up to your head and snow
what does the left say the left says but
weather isn't climate you can't point to
weather events and say that they're
evidence of climate change or not
evidence of climate okay all right fine
okay I accept that premise except you
only do that when it's convenient for
you the minute that you can point to
some disaster you say that was caused by
global warming any Club you are getting
covered in snow while she is declaring a
prayer that's not global warming but
that is global warming everything that's
convenient for me is global warming and
everything that's inconvenient for me is
not global warming weather is not
climate except when it's convenient for
Democrats and then you know honestly
MSNBC is being honest
for a little bit I never used the words
honestly in MSNBC in the same sentence
but they are being slightly honest here
they are pushing her they're saying why
why wouldn't you vote for it though and
she stammers and stammers but is that
kind argument that you just made to vote
YES for it I mean McConnell may be
trying to make it a show vote but if you
signed on to this you're one of the
co-authors of it if you believe that
this is something that even if it's
aspirational that needs to get done why
not take a stand and vote YES for it and
here's what the Democrats stand for we
don't care that it's a show vote it
seems like you're trying to have it both
ways
not be hung by it politically but also
not say that you don't support it I just
agree with you Katie that why should we
engaged in the kind of sham shenanigans
that Mitch McConnell is really good at
he's really good at offering to let
everyone vote on the thing that you guys
wrote and co-sponsored that's the [ __ ]
this is like what happens I mean good on
her good on this MSNBC lady for actually
trying to be somewhat honest and
consistent here and obviously mazie
Hirono has no answer to that but this is
like when you said I was in Michigan the
other day and I was talking to some of
the protesters at Ben's speech and they
were all talking about how we have to
all accept transgender STD ology and I
said okay but don't you think that this
creates a problem because it ultimately
erases the category of women if men can
be women and men can define femininity
and men can be the arbiters of what is
or what is not womanhood then don't you
diminish if not outright eliminate
women's agency and they said yeah that's
a bad faith question you're not arguing
in good faith that's a gotcha question
so I'm asking a perfectly logical
question that follows from your premises
I'm just there's what else could I say
that you would say is in good faith here
we have a clearer example of this in the
Senate they all say we want to vote on
this we want to vote we want to
co-sponsor this we wrote this and Mitch
McConnell says okay and they say you're
your
these are dirty tricks with the dirty
tricks of letting you do what you say
you want to do that's a dirty trick then
who's the dirty trickster you are she
see that goes on you have to hear the
end of this you have the hero she and
then you've got to hear the best the PS
tiller resistance the best part of
yesterday which is that Alexandria
Ocasio Cortes had to argue against her
own legislation but first we've got to
say goodbye to Facebook and YouTube go
over to Daley wire.com ten bucks a month
$100 for an annual membership you get me
at the end reclaim ensure you get the
Ben Shapiro show you to ask questions in
the mailbag coming up tomorrow get him
in you can test questions backstage
coming up tomorrow 7 p.m. Eastern 4 p.m.
Pacific our next episode of daily wire
backstage dealing wire god king jeremy
boring little ol me ben shapiro andrew
Clavin will be sipping whiskey smoke and
stogies and laughing our way through
politics and pop culture is always only
Daily wire subscribers get to ask the
questions so make sure to subscribe
today because of course you get this and
you talk about extreme weather events
that keep happening because of global
warming I think the extreme weather
events are happening because of the
total breakdown of the leftist narrative
and that's why you're seeing waves and
waves of salty tsunamis the only way to
survive them is to get your left is
tears tumblr go to daily wire calm we'll
be back with a lot more
so she keeps changing the subject she
keeps saying they say why didn't you
just vote for it though okay you're
saying Mitch McConnell wasn't gonna vote
for it it wasn't gonna pass okay but why
wouldn't you vote for it
okay maybe Mitch McConnell isn't doing
it because he thinks the green New Deal
is good or serious or going to pass the
Senate
but you guys co-sponsored it you guys
wrote it isn't it doesn't it just prove
Mitch McConnell's point if you don't
vote for it why not
vote for it and this finally is the best
she can muster so he's gonna keep doing
this kind of thing that his goal in life
is to try and divide the Democrats he
said that meantime he's just shoving as
many of the totally ideologically driven
judges through a court packing that he
can he's already said that to what first
of all he's not court packing the
Democrats are the ones advocating court
packing multiple presidential candidates
for the Democrats are now entertaining
the idea of and endorsing the idea of
adding justices to the Supreme Court
that's not what Mitch McConnell is doing
Mitch McConnell is just bringing up
judges for positions that already exist
as is his job and as is the president's
job what does court packing have to do
with this what are you actually if mazie
Hirono is saying that Mitch McConnell's
agenda in the Senate is so awful if he's
able to I mean she's using stupid
language that isn't true which she uses
the language of court packing but even
to say he's bringing up all of these
judicial nominees for confirmation votes
and that's really bad and that's
terrible for the country then shouldn't
you hamper his agenda by voting for a
legislation that you ostensibly want if
she is right if she says I don't want to
allow Mitch McConnell to enact his
agenda oh good then try to enact your
agenda he's giving you the opportunity
it's probably the only time he's gonna
give you the opportunity shouldn't you
all vote for it and then tie up the
Senate and two
ates and committee hearings and
negotiation was the president isn't that
what you should do no because you don't
believe in it is obviously you don't
believe in it he's offering you what you
want and you don't really believe in it
he called their bluff and they don't
want it here is the best that the author
of the green New Deal Alexandria Ocasio
Cortez here's the best that she could
muster on the subject of this vote
science should not be partisan this we
are facing a national crisis and if we
do not ascend to that crisis if we do
not ascend to the to the levels in which
we were threatened at the Great
Depression we were threatened in World
War two if we do not ascend to those
levels if we tell the American public
that we are more willing to invest and
bail out big banks than we are willing
to invest in our farmers and our urban
families then I don't know what we're
here doing I don't know what we're here
doing ma'am do you know what the word
ascends means yes congresswoman what
does the word ascend mean some some
people say it means an old old wooden
ship no man that no ma'am that's a line
from anchorman that's not that's not
what the word is sent I don't know what
the word ascends means it sounded really
good
I don't beyond her lack of familiarity
with the English language beyond her
lack of facility with the English
language she also is making a point that
doesn't make a lot of sense which is
that she has told us the world will end
in 12 years if we don't pass the green
new deal not just if we don't pass
environmentalist legislation not just if
we don't cap carbon emissions or stop
producing certain vehicles or whatever
she says the world will end in 12 years
all of life on Earth will be dead if we
do not pass her
Green New Deal a radical revolution all
of society all of our political system a
mobilization nothing short of what we
saw for world war two those are her
words and then cocaine Mitch says okay
let's vote on it and what does she do
she encourages all of those senators who
co-sponsored her her bill to vote
present I've been saying this for weeks
I have said I gave this speech last
night at the University of Redlands the
green New Deal has nothing to do with
environmentalism none of these people
really believes that the world will end
in 12 years none of the people
co-sponsoring the bill none of the
people writing the bill none of the
people talking about the bill with weird
language like Alexandre Ocasio Cortez
none of them really believes that the
world will end in 12 years because the
green New Deal is not about the natural
environment the green new deal is about
socialism it's about bringing about
socialism through the backdoor
it's about enacting the progressive
agenda that that the left has wanted for
a hundred years socialist health care
universal income universal job
guarantees massive redistribution of
wealth along racial and sexual lines a
massive grab of political and economic
Liberty from the people to the
bureaucrats to committees that can pass
any other program that they want to
according to the green New Deal
that's what it's all about nothing to do
with the environment and they know that
it's a political loser for them to do it
now so they don't think we're gonna die
in 12 years or I guess now what eleven
years and eleven months since she said
that they're just gonna wait and try to
affect their horrific and poisonous
agenda another way but the premise is
dead the premise was a hoax if there is
no way to more clearly demonstrate that
they don't believe the nonsense that
they're spewing then this green New Deal
vote it was a there's a political master
stroke by Mitch McConnell and he won the
greatest week ever continues speaking of
fakes frauds and hoaxers is there
anybody less genuine on planet earth and
Joe Biden is there anybody more
disingenuous and unctuous than Joe Biden
Joe Biden thinks he's going to run for
president he tried it in 1988 and he was
a faker he was a plagiarist he had to
drop out of that race tried it again in
2008 the only reason he got vice
president is because Barack Obama hated
Hillary Clinton so much so he got he
managed to worm his way into VP and now
he thinks he's gonna run again here is
how he's decided to launch his campaign
the question is is it gonna run as a
centrist or is he gonna run as a far
leftist I think we've got our answer
do something it's also because 28 years
ago I chaired the Senate Judiciary
Committee hearing the first of its kind
Clarence Thomas hearing appointment of a
lifetime a point of the Supreme Court
and a brave lawyer a really notable
woman Anita Hill professor showed the
courage of a lifetime talking about her
experience being harassed by Clarence
Thomas we knew a lot less about the
extent of harassment back then over 30
years ago but she paid a terrible price
she was abused for the hearing just
taking advantage of her reputation was
attacked I wish I could have done
something I opposed Clarence Thomas
nomination I voted against him but I
also realized there was a real and
perceived problem with committee faced
there are a bunch of white guys know I'm
a necessarily a bunch of white guys
hearing hearing this testimony in the
Senate Judiciary Committee so on anita
hill when they need help came to testify
she faced a committee that didn't fully
understand what the hell is all about so
I think the one thing that Uncle Joe
might have forgotten in his old age is
that if the problem is that there was a
committee of white guys who couldn't
possibly understand what black people
and women are going through and
therefore it was unfair for black and
black people and women
to go before a panel of white guys
Clarence Thomas is a black guy you dolt
the argument you've just made is that
anita hill didn't have a fair hearing
when she baselessly accused Clarence
Thomas of improper behavior because
she's a black woman Clarence Thomas is a
black man so he got an unfair hearing -
where's that where's that about so Joe
Biden I've never thought Joe Biden is
going anywhere
I think it's a joke that he's running in
2016 what's your 2020 rather what you
hear is Oh Joe he's gonna be the threat
to trump Joe he's Joe Biden is nothing
Joe Biden is a joke he's a punchline
that guy is going nowhere
Huna I could always be proven wrong I'm
just looking at the track record 1988 to
present he ain't going anywhere and so
he thinks his best hope is to downplay
the moderate downplay the centrism
downplay good old Uncle Joe from the
Rust Belt or whatever he thinks he can
affect and he is gonna run to the
intersectional left he thinks that's
gonna work for an old white guy and it
doesn't just stop there it doesn't just
stop with Anita Hill which was another
huge hoax and miscarriage of justice and
luckily Clarence Thomas was able to get
through but it was awful what they did
to him it was a high-tech lynching that
Joe Biden presided over I can't wait I
can't wait until Joe Biden runs for
president to bring that up that he
conducted a high-tech lynching for
uppity blacks who in any way deign to
think for themselves and he made it
clear that if you don't kowtow to an old
order you will be mocked humiliated and
caricatured before a committee of the US
Senate rather than hung from a tree
Clarence Thomas's words not mine but
then he goes more radical he gets way
more extreme he questions the
anglo-american system of justice itself
this is English jurist financial culture
a white man's culture it's got to change
it's got to change
English jurisprudential culture equals a
white man's culture that's that's his
claim English jurisprudential culture
he's not he doesn't just mean English he
means Anglo American because we take our
system of justice and jurisprudence from
the English and he's saying our criminal
justice system is fundamentally racist
and sexist it is fundamentally bigoted
it is fundamentally illegitimate and we
need to get rid of our entire system of
jurisprudence that's the most radical
statement that any potential 2020
presidential candidate has made that's
probably the most radical statement that
any presidential candidate has made in
my lifetime now the thing about Joe
Biden is that he frequently says stupid
things and then he contradicts them
later on so probably that's what's
happening here
also he frequently makes outrageous race
hustling claims he said did this in 2012
to remember when Mitt Romney was running
and he said Mitt Romney he wants to put
you all back in Chains before an
entirely black audience or a mostly
black audience what is English
jurisprudential culture it's equality
before the law
it's the presumption of innocence it's
due process it is the most just
jurisprudential culture in the history
of the world it's the it's the only
reason that we even have a sense in our
legal system of non-discrimination
fairness equality that that's why
because of English jurisprudential
culture
he says that's got to change and he's
saying that in a calculated way because
the left does want that to change the
left hates the presumption of innocence
the left hates that Clarence Thomas that
there wasn't evidence against him and
that he got to go to the Supreme Court
and they couldn't just lynch him the
left hates that certain groups aren't
given special privileges the left
hates that brick Cavanaugh couldn't just
be smeared with constantly changing
contradictory nonsense accusations they
hate that they want to see special
privileges for favored racial and sexual
groups they want Jessie Smollett to get
off the hook because he's a
well-connected famous black gay guy
that's what they want so what does this
mean for 2020 this means Joe Biden is
not going to run as a moderate what this
also means is that Joe Biden who has
been plotting his presidential run since
I donate e8 certainly in 1987 1986 and
he's been plotting this next run since
he was vice president he felt that he
couldn't take on Hillary in 2016 so now
he thinks he can take on the field this
means he thinks he can't run as a
moderate he thinks it ain't gonna work
and he's probably right the only reason
I think he's probably making the wrong
bet here is let's say there's a 97%
chance that the Democrat nominee is some
far leftist which is why virtually all
of the candidates are jumping over
themselves to prove themselves the most
radical leftist they're all
co-sponsoring the green new deal even
though they don't vote for it let's say
they're all trying to jump we want
reparations for slavery we want 107
trillion dollars worth of new social
programs we want all these things there
are certain polls that show that
Democrat voters think they've gone too
far that maybe they want more of a
moderate more of a centrist not the
loudest voices not even maybe the donors
but the majority of the country
especially in states that they want to
win and Joe Biden is not going to be the
most far left candidate he simply can't
be because inherent in this radical left
ISM is the sort of identity racial and
sexual identity politics that Joe Biden
is trying to embrace here but he can't
embrace it because he's an old white guy
who's been in Congress and there was
been in the Senate since he was what
since the 70s this guy's been in the
government for most of his life it ain't
gonna work he cannot do it the only
chance
he has is to run for that 3% centrist
moderate can relate to the Rust Belt
kind of vote and he seems not to be
doing that because while it might be his
best chance he doesn't think it's the
best chance to get the nomination which
means he's probably going nowhere which
means the best week ever continues we'll
get to David Brooks and cardi B tomorrow
I know talk about a cliffhanger get your
mailbag questions in in the meantime on
Michael knows this is the Michael Nolt
show see tomorrow the Michael Noel's
show is produced by Robert Sterling
executive producer Jeremy Moore senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis clever and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Dani D'Amico audio is mixed by
Dylan case hair and makeup is by Jessa
of era production assistant Nick Sheehan
the Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright day Lee Weyer 2019
hey everyone I'm Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know Chicago
has a reputation as a corrupt Democrat
machine town because it's a corrupt
Democrat machine town we saw that
yesterday in the justice Millette case
we saw it for eight years during the
Obama administration it's not a question
of Al Capone where Democrats gather it's
all Capone I'm Andrew Clavin that's on
the Andrew Clavin show